bienvenidos a este programa especial la
serie en france 24 enfocado en los retos
que enfrentará el presidente entrante de
eeuu joe biden
soy andrés meza muñoz la inmigración ha
sido un tema espinoso en eeuu
especialmente durante la era de donald
trump se estima que en el país hay unos
11 millones de indocumentados el
presidente entrante joe biden se
comprometió a presentar un proyecto de
reforma migratoria en los primeros 100
días de su gobierno uno de los grandes
retos que tendrá el líder demócrata los
primeros en beneficiarse de esta reforma
serían los llamados gamers más de
700.000 jóvenes que llegaron al país de
manera irregular cuando eran niños y que
aún no tienen papeles nuestro
corresponsal
anthony belchí habló con una de ellas
ya me toca empezar a aplicar escuelas
porque ahorita es el tiempo que están
agarrando a hanjin si lleva casi toda la
vida en eeuu llegó a los 2 años al sur
de la florida procedente de honduras
pero lo hizo ilegalmente junto a su
madre y ahora no tiene papeles vive con
el miedo de que en cualquier momento
pueda ser deportada a un país que ni
siquiera conoce y todo este tiempo he
estado en un limbo porque no sé cómo voy
a seguir una carrera normal como
persiguiera una diploma de la
universidad sin el papel que me falta
aunque me siento más americana que
hondureña
es una más de los 700.000 jóvenes
soñadores los trimmers que han podido
acogerse al programa daca barack obama
lo impulsó en 2012 por orden ejecutiva
para que pudieran tener un estatus
temporal
trump ha luchado sin suerte para
cerrarles la puerta ahora y en si está
esperanzada con que la nueva
administración y ambas cámaras de
mayoría demócrata aprueben una reforma
migratoria definitiva ahora que el
gobierno senado y el congreso son del
mismo color me siento muy esperanzada
que va a haber cambio de verdad y
efectivo para nuestras comunidades
nuestra
en la lucha la de los dreamers que ha
sido apoyada por cientos de
organizaciones en todo el país o lo que
necesitamos de forma urgente y de forma
crítica ya es una permanencia para
nuestros casi 12 millones de personas
indocumentadas muchos de ellos trabajan
los sectores esenciales como lo que es
agrícola en el sector de salud la
mayoría de los republicanos ya ha
expresado su rechazo a la reforma
consideran que un cambio en la
legislación vigente provocaría un
aumento de los flujos migrantes al país
tratarán de todas maneras de entrar los
eeuu en espera de estatal a amnistía
aquí no va a haber como ni siquiera
ayudar a los que están en la fila
esperando su turno
pero la administración baiden ya ha
avisado una reforma no dará vía libre a
la entrada ilegal su prioridad es
encontrar una solución para todos los
indocumentados que actualmente no gozan
de una protección legal en eeuu
el programa de baile en cuestión
migratoria contempla varias propuestas
entre ellas detener la construcción del
muro en la frontera con mexico revertir
las políticas que separan a los niños de
sus padres respetar las leyes de asilo
para quienes soliciten este beneficio en
su país
el partido republicano ha criticado
duramente al presidente electo
asegurando que si se impulsa una reforma
migratoria provocaría un efecto llamada
en algunos países de américa latina como
las caravanas de inmigrantes que llegan
hasta la frontera a la espera de un
asilo será una reforma abierta a todos
los inmigrantes que quieren ir a estados
unidos en busca de una vida mejor el
abogado especializado en inmigración muy
real en explica con más detalle esta
propuesta legislativa que podría ver la
luz muy pronto en eeuu
sabemos que las caravanas que salen en
centroamérica y que tienen persona en el
mundo entero en ella el trato a su
humano por traficante es un negocio de
olvido las personas que están pensando
hacer piénselo no van a entrar los eeuu
no le van a una residencia en la
frontera no le va a dar un cheque de
ayuda económica y no le van a arreglar
una casa un carro
no va a ocurrir este no es el momento de
hacerlo este es el momento de que hay
que respetar las leyes los eeuu litro de
obama ni vaina ahora
va a permitir entradas ilegal en los
estados unidos según control
de olvidarse de las caravanas olvídense
de demandas de entradas
olvídense de tomas de puentes igual que
fracaso la toma el capitolio fracasan
demandas se es forzada pero es por tu
mente a los eeuu es la misma no es la
misma cosa pero tienes va a tener el
mismo resultado no sea no va a poder
ganar
hasta aquí la serie de france 24 ésta y
otras ediciones sobre los retos de joe
biden el cambio climático y la política
extranjera lo pueden encontrar a través
de nuestra página web www puntos
france24 puntocom quédense con nosotros
no